morning it is march madness for a great
cause it's opportunity village giving
you a chance to win prizes and support a
great organization that's right and
we've got hector mejia joining us live
talking about the march to 100k
fundraising for local people with
disabilities hi hector good morning i
see you have the basketball now
i sure do good morning guys i mean i had
to practice uh so yeah we're at the
campus here we're talking about this
great chance to help a great local
non-profit joining us i've got kristin
she's an ambassador i'm going to give
her the microphone so first while i
shoot this tell us what you do here i
do art
i perform
and
i
i'm an ambassador so as you're an
ambassador you also uh shoot some hoops
right yeah show us so you also shoot
some hoops and so we're highlighting
this great opportunity right now during
march madness it's building on the
excitement around march madness and it's
called hoops hoopla it's essentially the
bracket here for march madness and uh
opportunity village is hoping to raise a
hundred thousand dollars to support a
lot of the programs out here and kristen
come over here and talk to us a little
bit more so tell us how opportunity
village has helped you and a lot of
people here that you know i've worked
here for almost 12 years
and i
do
made lots of friends since i've
worked here
and you also live here on campus right
that's also a really cool thing about it
yes
and you've also been able to learn how
to expand your skills when it comes to
art and tamp dancing tell us why is that
so cool for you personally because it's
an opportunity to perform
and
[Music]
work and perform out in public that's
fantastic and i also hear that you love
basketball right yes
alright thank you for your time so i
will be posting all of the details
here's one more look at the uh hoops
hoopla bracket if you want to enroll the
website for that is march to
100k.com we'll be posting everything on
eightnewsnow.com as well reporting live
hector mejia and tell us your name one
more time kristen a back to you guys
love that hector thank you very much uh
kristin working on her shot hector
hector sung his shot too i know good
stuff all right